for stephen braun overall the era of 404
looking for a second win tonight
well there you go
strikeout of contreras
swinging a miss runner goes throw down
and how about a strike come out throw
him out inning ending double play
that's beautiful right there that cleans
things up nice one ball and two strikes
strike three
and the inning ends so stephen bralt
right back at him
and one two three second inning jose
quintana will make
his first start of the season
he got him painted on the inside edge
two balls and a strike on eric gonzalez
the two one swinging a line drive to
right heading toward the corner and this
one's gonna drop down ahead to the wall
polanco's in easily and gonzales heading
into second base he'll drift in with a
two-out rbi double the pirates on the
board one to nothing
new pitcher at barrett al zillai in
relief of jose quintana
jared oliver batts hits a ground ball to
the hole at short backhanded by bias
good strong throw gets him by a step or
two
has made a difficult play look almost
routine
fires home on a 2-2
and he got reynolds on a pitch that
ended up way out of the
zone swing and a missed strike three he
strikes out hayes back-to-back
strikeouts for house alive terrorist hit
and the next pitch rizzo is hits javier
baez
hard hit picked by hayes turns what
looked like a sure rbi single into a
double play here's the pitch the swing
of the miss he struck him out threw the
fastball in on him
and brault strikes out kyle schwarber
swinging a miss he got him swinging it's
three straight
two and two
it's number five for brompton
on his horse reynolds toward the right
center gap he makes an exceptional play
in right center field brian reynolds
robbing
martinez of extra bases albert also in
his third inning of work
he got him
boy that slider has
been a baffler adam frazier fly down in
the second
there goes polanco again this ball's
rope toward right center field and that
will get polanco home adam frazier
into second base as polanco heads toward
the plate
and that ball is cut off and frazier
will be thrown out give frazier credit
for an rbi double and give the pirates
a two-nothing lead here comes the
one-two offering owls ally
to oliva call strike three as it nips
the outside portion of the plate stephen
brought 75 pitches through five innings
he's given up one infield hit
broke his bat
and polanco
yeah another scoreless inning ho-hum
stephen brawl just moving right along
let's see if alzheimer can keep the cubs
within two one and two on reynolds
a couple of uh as he strikes them out
six for owls
now this is a big spot you've got met at
second and third two down jacob
stallings at the plate
nasty stuff seven strikeouts for al's
alive
we're all back out there
for this seventh inning
he did
maybe he didn't get up quite as high as
he wanted to but he
does the job and he gets the strikeout
and he has punched out six
through seven scoreless innings
sam howard has her pitching change he'll
face anthony rizzo
as rizzle pulls this one to right and it
is gone
he didn't get him out and we're tied two
to two
what an impressive swing in the bat for
anthony rizzo single to center last time
up this time he goes deep off the lefty
howard that is his 10th homer of the
year and his first with a runner on base
there is stallings oh for three with a
couple of strikeouts
oh fly ball to left safer
near the foul pole
and
tommy raise the jolly roger
jacob stallings
clears the deck with a game-winning
cannonball
his first career walk-off home run and
the bucks defeat the cubbies third home
run of the season
third career walk-off hit for jacob
stallings